welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and Quentin Tarantino's once upon
a time in Hollywood it's one of my
favorite films of the year the story of
Hollywood's darkest night retold as a
bloody tarantino fairy tale the way all
history should have played house with
critically praised performances by
Leonardo DiCaprio Brad Pitt and Margot
Robbie Tarantino's acclaimed ninth film
is available in stores in online on 4k
Ultra HD blu-ray DVD and digital along
with 20 minutes of additional scenes and
an exclusive behind-the-scenes look the
crafts that made this film so great the
production design the cinematography the
costume designed the carves I'm gonna
break down all this additional footage
the cool details that you might have
overlooked and once upon a time in
Hollywood
you weren't even if you have not seen it
yet and thank you to Sony Pictures for
sponsoring this video
Sonia was nice enough to send me the
different versions of Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood each has some amazing
collectables included I'm gonna get to
all of them but this is the National
blu-ray and it contains if you were to
open it up here both of the DVD with the
amazing film and all the bonus material
but if you're a real Tarantino fan a few
collector a Tarantino we know that's
probably Method am I just made it up
check out this limited collector's
edition this thing is awesome
it opens up like a 45 it includes this
Mad Magazine mini edition it's like in
the universe it includes some like part
of Rick Dalton the way Mad Magazine was
shown it and includes this vintage
poster that will be going up on my wall
very cool an actual 45 a vinyl record
it's got two songs in the soundtrack
notice how the art shows Rick Dalton's
appearance on the hullaballoo show which
brings us to our first additional scene
in which Rick sings Jim Lowe's green
door on hullabaloo which was an actual
NBC musical variety series in the 60s
you look into the lyrics of green door
the song actually reflects Rick's
situation in this film because it's
about a singer who can't sleep because
the music coming for a nearby club so it
goes over knocks on its green door but
then it gets turned away from the
private club
Rick similarly is the next door neighbor
to history an outsider looking in at the
party and in this film's fairy tale
twist ending to the fate of Sharon Tate
and a Manson family Rick finally gets
admitted into this private party also
included in the bonus material are
commercials for old Chattanooga beer
which is the brand that cliff boots
drinks in this movie and Tarantino's
recurring in universe cigarette label
red apple there's also a clip from
Rick's Western series bounty law
featuring Tarantino collaborator Michael
Madsen as a sheriff that episode is
sponsored by red apple and tweet
keys which also appear in the additional
scene that I was most excited to see an
extended scene showing Charles Manson
continuing to look for Terry Melcher
after he scoped out the house with Jay
Sebring in it Terry Melcher was the
music producer and former resident of
the Polanski Tate house Manson rambles
on to a manager about signing him he
mentions his free friendship with Dennis
Wilson of the Beach Boys which actually
did exist before Manson and his women
were kicked out of the house Manson
claims to a Brittany peachoid song but
the manager shoes him away while his dog
bandit won't stop barking perhaps
foreshadowing his dog brandy attacking
Manson's followers later in the film
Manson heads back to the Twinkie truck
that he was driving nearly since his
cliff watching him from the roof next
door and he gives cliff the scariest
wave cliff doesn't return it so Manson
suddenly freaks out with like it's a
karate moves and profanities now there
are two more additional scenes to check
out both from the set of the new CBS
Western that Rick guest stars in Lancer
the first shows Timothy Olyphant and
Luke Perry as the Lancer Brothers as
they meet the young Mary Bella the
director cranes in and complements a
girl's scene Hayley Mills eat your heart
out a nod to the child actors from the
original Parent Trap
now this director is Sam Wanamaker
played by Nicholas Hammond Wanamaker was
a famous theatre director known for his
restoration of the Globe Theatre in
London the second Lancer additional
scene is a one-take chat between
Wanamaker in rick without the acting
crap
it's pretty hilarious Wanamaker tells
rick about a new script that he's
writing called the executioner
where you don't know whether the lead
character is good or bad or an innocent
bystander until the very end
much like Rick and clip in this film who
come off as innocent bystanders but
actually have a pivotal role in the fate
of history here now if you're a
collector you may also be interested to
know that this once upon a time in
Hollywood blu-ray release also includes
gifts with purchase offered at retail at
Best Buy
you'll get a collectible steelbook and
image of brandy and then in the target
one there's an in world film magazine
with articles about Rick taught me and
cliff booth in Hollywood night parties
and then if the Walmart one comes with
these exclusive collectible postcards
there's Rick Dalton Ringo gringo opera
zone' dynomite Nebraska Jim Tanner and
the Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
Illustrated poster the same way that the
film immerses us in Hollywood in the
1960s these bonus gifts keep that party
going I love that the film includes all
these ways to appreciate it because
really what made it so great is the
whole book in the design turn Tina grew
up in Hollywood in the 60s and 70s and
the way to the
suddenly revises Hollywood history works
so well because the two hours that
preceded the twist worked so hard to
make us feel that we were actually
watching real authentic history unfolds
the documentaries included in the
blu-ray release explore all the crap
that went into that authenticity
production designer Barbara link
discusses how she shut down Hollywood
Boulevard for four blocks to redecorate
store windows and restore each of the
old marquees on theater row so that they
list the films that were plain in August
1969 customer Aaron Philips discusses
how she met with Sharon Tate's sister to
get samples of Sharon Tate's clothes and
jewelry and how she recreated Tate's
famous snakeskin trench coat that she
warded the Rosemary's Baby premiere
which we see merggle Robbie we're in
this movie and if you're into classic
cars definitely be sure to check out the
documentary with the film's car
coordinators Steven butcher and Leonard
Jefferson who snuck in a ton of
historical Easter eggs into the film
Cliff's car has no hubcaps because he's
a stuntman and stunt drivers wouldn't
put hubcaps on their cars and they
reused the Cadillac from Tarantino's
Reservoir Dogs as the hero car that
cliff drives Rick in and Roman
Polanski's car is a 1930s mg Roadster
which Tarantino selected from the film
model shop and for the Manson Family car
butcher and Jefferson actually tracked
down the real car driven by Tex Watson
that night the collector offered to let
them use it for the film but they felt
it would be too morbid to shoot the
actors in the actual car so they took
pictures and recreated the car so that
the scratches and breasts matched
perfectly all of this design was shot
beautifully by the director of
photography Bob Richardson who used lots
of film varieties 70 millimeter 35
millimeter the episodes of bounty law
and 16 black and whites home movie
footage shot in super 8 as a film about
the film and TV industry all the movies
that the characters watching the movie
needed to look like movies did when you
watch them back then featurette goes
into one of Tarantino's craziest shots
one that cranes from Rick in his pool
over the roofs of the houses down to
Tate and Polanski next door as they head
out for the night this is one of the
most critical shots of the film because
it lays out the geography of Rick's life
relative spatially to the history of
Sharon Tate and the Manson's the
unbroken long take synchronizes these
separate timelines to set up the
precision of the way they collide in the
final act to change Hollywood history
with a fairytale Indian that it deserved
an eventful but relatively non historic
night now
so that Tate and the others could define
their legacies the way that they should
have
able to again Quentin Tarantino's
acclaimed ninth film once upon a time in
Hollywood is now available on 4k Ultra
HD blu-ray DVD and digital with
critically praised performances from
Leonardo DiCaprio Brad Pitt Margot
Robbie and loaded with over twenty
minutes of additional scenes and
exclusive access to the set get your
copy today follow me on instagram and
twitter at Avis and subscribe to new
rock stars for breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching
[Music]